happy friday reject nation we're gonna
watch from marvel marvel spider-man
miles morales spider-man into the
spider-verse suit reveal looks like
mazda ross is gonna be getting the suit
from spider-verse in here that's so cool
we are obviously wearing star wars
shirts because
right after this is up we're gonna start
shooting uh the first reaction for the
mandalorian so subscribe and hit that
notification bell to get notified when
that video was up it should be up either
tomorrow
or sunday doing what we can to get it up
by tomorrow
takes a while to edit guys anywho let's
swing into action i get it swing
hi everyone i'm justin k thompson and i
am the production designer for
spider-man
into the spider hi justin when we were
working on the animated film the most
exciting part of the process was
bringing miles morales to life on the
big screen for the first time
in a way that had never been seen before
look at the reflection
as glasses the
[Laughter]
the ring light's right here it's like
he's beaming into
take on the yourself in marvel's
spider-man miles morales
coming out for ps5 and ps4 the way
insomniac faithfully brought the iconic
suit designed for spider-man into the
spider-verse into the game
is visually stunning and remarkable i
believe here we were able to advise
on some of the unique design elements
that made the film so distinct
like how we often animated the
characters on twos
and we made recommendations for how best
to integrate the pop-up words and the
little burst cards on the screen
into the action sequences oh sweet
hey oh cool i'm excited to see it
i didn't even think about doing them
doing that oh
they changed the frame rate up shoot the
two enemies no way
yeah that's so cool wow
oh nice whoa so is that like specific to
this particular suit it must be
super impressive that is super
impressive
did not see that coming wow
and i wonder if it's a very simple
adjustment
like it yeah oh i love it but it makes
all the difference
all right that is mind-blowing man
oh i love how they choose to know i love
the swinging backwards
love it i just i love how he swings like
kind of amateurish i love it but also
with his own style
yeah look at him look at him go
yes oh this is so cool
i just want to vr this
oh this is so awesome
oh and it's even got the like red blue
green
yeah like ghosting
[Music]
finish it
oh
that was awesome ouch i must use a lot
of energy
he must have to eat a lot
zap
so happy neighborhood
[Music]
man they've really brought this to life
that is nuts
i kind of prefer it for the nostalgia of
the movie
wow they really love their fans huh
it seems like you really get the
impression they love their fans
hey man i wanted to be friends with the
guy at the beginning of the video so
oh spider cat
i think i'm just a cat oh damn
something's weakening emergency
responder communications
you should check it out yeah you should
yeah keep keep checking stuff out in
your cool frame rate
so the rest of the world is still on
ones though right
like it's still like the world is moving
extra fluid and then he stands out from
it
i think so that's how it strikes me i
mean either way it looks amazing
i mean it kind of makes him pop more
yeah exactly yeah
spiderman thank god something's
weakening our emergency costs
we can't get through the fire department
is anyone still inside
no we got everyone out but this buyer is
going to jump if we don't get help
hear that just noise now can you imagine
how crazy it would be
don't worry look they've even got the
comic book like newsprint shading on it
when they zoom in
[Music]
i love how he swings it's so different
i love it
yeah it's like he doesn't yet have like
a a worn-in routine
so yeah so it's like different it's very
jazzy
it's kind of like compower in the air
yeah
you sure you
feels so lived in so limited
now spit on that guy's head
nice you can't fraud spider-man
insurance
you got this hey mr emt
you are trying to burn down that
building for an insurance scam
that's why they're missing with your
comms
you're putting people in danger yeah
how's the fire
oneplus
the dual shock like
i've committed it to memory how to do it
and with the sun there too lighting's
beautiful
the sky is gorgeous here
i'm getting close
this also is helping to emphasize just
how much energy and effort it takes to
be spiders
yeah the sky the way they've animated
the sky is brilliant
you must be an actual human being miles
just murdered that guy
no my spider-man snapped his neck he
just grabs one of the dude's guns
i love when the words pop up
oh man i cannot wait
i really cannot wait
damn
and assault wrapping them off yeah leave
no survivor
spider gun spider
hey how's the signal now
now we got so many fire trucks i have a
question i was never
able to figure out if there was a way
just to like transport
to well you know we're swinging two on
the map basically this is what i'm
talking about
so if you could just like zap yeah i
didn't know if there was a way to like
download something
or upgrade to something to zap to
something because they've been
you know it's been a very long time
swinging into something a lot of times
it's always fun though
yeah i don't know if you guys know
there's a way to do it that i never
figured out
is there a way to not have to just
retrace your entire
swing i mean you master the art of
swinging
from this process though like a real
spiderman
punch this emt fire department got the
billiards team was just in time
i'm definitely giving your at five stars
the more people used to have the safer
we'll make new york i'm going to make
sure everybody knows about it
thanks again spider-man it's too welcome
i'm joining the spider-man street team
is that a little genki lee guy mom was
right
it's a taiko ytd from greenland oh good
nobody looks at us
i want to be able to do this in real
life
that's so trippy how they brought him to
life with the from the spider-verse
animation
he that was amazeballs
i'm a huge fan of comic books i'm a fan
of you excited that fans like me will
get the opportunity to play the game
with
miles morales in the league role thank
you to insomniac
our friends at playstation and marvel
games for inviting me to be a part of
this video
we can't wait to see it all come
together
[Music]
bravo bravo i mean i feel like we set
everything in there it's one of those
rare cases
we were like literally set everything in
the reaction that we usually say for the
review portion
absolutely loved it i thought it was
brilliant man i was like all right cool
spider suit reveal
awesome i don't really know what that
means other than
it's gonna look exactly like the
spider-verse one but uh right away i was
like whoa
that's surprising they changed the frame
rate up
yeah well it's such a simple trick you
know yeah and it's something to me that
watching him swing around i loved the
marriage of how video games have gotten
so detailed and so hyper real and yet
you can also drop in this element that
makes it feel uncannily like a comic or
like a cartoon yeah
and it really popped like you said in
the video popped really nice popped
really nice
the words on stream were great yeah
really so
the way they handled the weather in the
sky it was i i don't know why my eye was
occasionally being really drawn to that
but i thought they animated that
beautifully
it's really soothing we've talked so
much about this game
already and uh it's just the more they
reveal the better it just keeps
getting guys all right well what'd you
think of this spider suit reveal
were you as impressed as we were leave
your thoughts down below hit that like
button
subscribe click the notification bell
keep a lookout for amanda reaction
gotta get that ps5 baby gotta get that
penis player